Okay,
here we go.
In five,
four,
three,
two,
one,
boom.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Joe Schilling and Daniel Straus.
Fucking house Joe Shillings.
Just fucking up my kick machine out
there,
man.
That thing ain't read and write.
I mean,
I hope not.
I really hurt my ego up.
You are lightened up.
Fuck her on fire.
That thing is not.
We got to get that recalibrate.
It tells in here complaining about a
sciatic pain and this hip and still
kicked me in like what is going on?
I hear most sweaty.
Forget about sciatic pain.
Daniel Straus.
You've gone through some fucking pain.
Dude,
you are defying science and doctors and
David telling you it was over.
Tell everybody the whole story.
Put this,
bring this sucker up here at a story
goes.
I was out one night,
buddy of mine was having trouble and
needed somebody to go out.
Welcome.
So,
uh,
was around the city that night and um,
after taking him home we were leaving
the highway.
Has it split off?
I was coming around was like yeah,
I was on a bike.
So.
And I had a passenger.
So what was called eight,
26 is the highway as the splits off to
95.
I was going around eight,
26.
Now here's the tricky part.
I don't really remember what's going on
from there.
So the men and the passenger,
remember we were hit from either the
side or from the back.
Um,
but coming around the bend boom,
coming around,
got pushed into the wall.
I'll wake up under the,
a guard rail,
can't move,
you know,
nobody else is there and the car is
gone.
There was not really a witness there
until like later pulling up behind us.
So it fucked me up for awhile.
I mean fuck me up right now.
But,
you know,
uh,
getting back to just what it is,
the body's healing.
And then.
So what was the extent of your injuries?
All right.
So,
uh,
I had,
um,
in my c four,
five and six,
I had contusions on my spinal cord and
half a mile on the left side of my
spinal quarter was a pressure so bad
that it shut down my whole nervous
system,
like all my body.
So a mix up in my neck and then my
middle of my back was just compressed a
lot of the swelling and that's what,
uh,
caused a lot of the,
you know,
not being able to walk,
not being able to feel the nervous
problems.
Never system that I have or the nervous,
uh,
issues that I had.
So what did they do to fix it?
I've been rehabbing a,
they wanted to do surgery right away,
but how many months ago was this?
This was in December.
This was September 17th.
So,
um,
they wanted to do or they wanted to do a
surgery immediately.
You know what I'm trying to tell them,
like,
no,
I'm,
I'm trying to fight again,
blah,
blah.
What kind of surgery?
Fusion.
That's what they wanted to.
They wanted to go in and take the,
I think the,
I want to say the three to the five or
four to six or something,
fuse that altogether,
which obviously there's no rain that's.
And it's a big spot.
So a wasn't trying to have that looked
up for.
We looked for,
you know,
a couple of rehab places and eventually
got hooked up with a place called a
neural fit,
three 60.
So I've been rehabbing there since the
accident and I mean it's weird in
Europe,
pembroke Pines,
Florida,
close to Miami,
a great crew.
But yeah,
they've been giving me back in the game.
I've been a,
I was doing that extensively every day
for like two days a week,
two hour or couple of hours a day,
you know,
two to three times a day.
What kind of shit that they do for your
neck?
Uh,
for more.
For me,
first we had to start with um,
you know,
just the um,
the fine motor stuff,
touching,
feeling,
you know,
I had problems with my sensitivities.
So like,
you wake up onto the guard rail,
you know,
you guys don't remember what happened
when you wake up in the hospital where
they're telling you for.
They got all of this stuff.
They were like,
oh,
to walk.
Could you feel,
could you like how were you when you
woke up for me?
Um,
when I woke up,
boom.
Yeah.
So back to the store when I woke up,
when I woke up,
so I woke up and uh,
you know,
I had my helmet on but I couldn't move
my legs.
My passenger had one over top.
She had her hands so she wasn't like
extremely,
but she had went out to.
So I couldn't really feel nothing
because nothing.
I was just telling him to get my helmet
off and get my helmet off.
Finally had a truck,
had pulled up and seen that we were in
an accident and they,
what they shouldn't do,
but pull me out and uh,
yeah,
because I was supposed to touch anybody,
get me out of there,
you know,
I was freaking out.
They pull me out from under it and uh,
you know,
going into the hospital,
that whole,
the scary part was,
was knowing nothing was broke but not
being able to feel nothing.
Trying to wipe my face or trying to grab
something and you just couldn't move my
head in my head.
I'm moving my leg,
I move my arm,
nothing's going on.
You know what I'm saying?
So you're thinking you're paralyzed.
I'm gone.
It's a wrap like Paul Williams.
Yeah.
I'm just like,
fuck.
So I get to the hospital finally.
Um,
you know,
they're trying to work on me and seeing
the doctors.
He's telling me,
well,
you know,
because of my neck,
it's unlikely that I'll be walking
anytime soon.
No,
a couple of days,
couple of weeks ago after that,
you know,
just banging.
And in the meantime I'm trying to
explain to them I'm an athlete.
I know you see this.
I've been through this type of incident
before,
you know,
I grew up wrestling.
I'm from Cincinnati,
grew up wrestling,
so I've had neck problems for fuck my
whole life,
you know what I mean?
And uh,
so I'm trying to explain to him like,
you know,
chill out.
Just give me some time.
Let me,
let me work something out.
I don't want to do the surgery right
now.
I really want to.
They want you to do it in the hospital
right there.
Right.
Then there was no other,
you know,
there's no other choice.
You never gonna walk again.
Do you want to go back to them right now
and go,
hey motherfucker,
look,
look who's walking around know,
you know what I mean?
And it's been like that majority of
times in my career where I've done
something,
something's happening.
Oh,
you're not gonna be able to do this.
You got me fucked up.
Right.
He's hitting pads with me at the gym
yesterday.
The guy sparring this happened in
December.
That's insane.
It's just insane.
It just makes me sick that they always
want to cut you immediately when it
comes to any kind of bulging disc issue.
They want to get in there and it's
hurtful to us because,
you know,
I understand they got a job to do,
but do your job.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like they have one method,
one method of surgery.
So,
um,
but yeah,
like I said,
I was rehabbing that neural fit three,
six d,
which is a great physical therapy place
down there in pembroke pines.
And uh,
you know,
I've been getting back with me,
strengthen my neck,
which is small exercises.
Like I said,
I started with fine motor stuff where I
had to work on a lot of balance stuff,
you know,
um,
you ever fuck with that iron neck thing?
You ever used that thing yet?
No,
I have not used out here.
I'm trying if you want to mess around
with it and he's fantastic.
Fantastic.
So you are six months out now.
Six months out.
When did you start walking again?
It took me like,
even now I'm still like trying to get
the form right.
But uh,
it took me about three months because
she was like read,
learned how we learned how to tie her
shoe in my hand.
My Motor,
like my hand wasn't moving his right.
It wasn't working as good.
It's just everything slowed down for me
because of my spinal cord.
So wow,
you know,
that is the most for me was the scariest
part because I was everything so unsure,
you know what I mean?
The most recent MRI.
When did you get,
have you gotten a gv one?
About a month and a half ago.
And whenever you look good,
it looks good.
All the swelling went down.
Um,
the left side is clear,
the only way I can explain it,
there's two,
two months,
white lines and it gets blocked.
You know what I'm saying?
That's where the fluids coming down.
My left side of my,
on the fluid was being blocked.
So now I'm having a clear line of fluid
going down my spinal cord.
Now it's just about healing,
which,
you know,
I've been working.
That's the part to get overcome the
healing part,
the neurological part and the nerves and
all that part that goes with it.
It's the body that can only.
There's not too much that I can do to
tell this other than,
you know,
eating right,
all the simple shit,
but it's the body that's telling.
But it's crazy that you're sparring.
Yeah,
I do a lot of things.
I shouldn't do your spine with friends,
so you know,
that everything's going to be cool.
I mean,
good trading partners.
I was down at Henry who's h kickboxing
was training down there.
Um,
so you know,
I live in Fort Lauderdale,
so you,
that's,
you know,
working out with those guys,
no one's out there to hurt me or tried
to get me hurt or injured.
Everyone's had a lot of respect and love
seeing me back.
So I've never been in a situation where
I'm trying to go super hard.
Not yet,
but I love to.
You can get,
we can get it.
So when you hitting the bag or hitting
pads,
you feel like you have full strength?
No,
no,
no.
And that's the thing that I'm,
that I'm excited about.
I'm a broken toward that is dying to be
fixed,
you know what I mean?
Because I'm a brand new,
you know,
I can be fixed in any way.
Like I'm relearning everything.
I'm not,
you know,
it's not like I can't box,
it's not like I can't wrestle,
but it's now just relearning the,
you know,
the mechanics of making your brain knows
how to do it,
but your body's got to relearn it.
Exactly why?
And it's like the nerve,
the nerve stuffs is on the right side of
your body,
right?
It's like muscle memory coming back.
Even yesterday I was holding pads from
like,
his job was a little weak and like his
is a lifting of his foot or whatever the
thing we're trying to do,
but once as we are doing it,
once he felt the right way to do it,
then he could repeat it,
you know what I mean?
So it was a lot to do with it
and is big for me,
man.
I really want to be back in the cage by
the end of this year.
Really.
You know what I mean?
I want,
wouldn't be fighting about an issue here
and it's not impossible.
Well you got a great attitude man.
This idea that you love it,
that you're a broken toy and you got to
rebuild it and fix it and it's exciting
for sure.
It gives you an opportunity to kinda
start again.
I mean that's been my whole life my
whole life.
So I'm just there again at this point in
my career and unfortunately this had to
happen for me to turn the corner and get
focused in another way.
But you know,
it's just what it has to be,
but it's so exciting that you have this
attitude that's the.
That's the cool thing about it.
It's like you're not,
woe is me.
You're like,
Hey,
I'm on a rebuild,
but let me get right back in there.
You must be so excited that you could
just do everything again.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like first was finding out what we're
headed,
making sure that Dick work
first,
live on,
always fuck off my back.
So just making sure I could do shit,
you know?
No,
the first,
first couple months was just brutal,
you know,
not being a.
When I asked him to eat,
did it slowly start to come back where
you got like some motion?
Well,
I've had a lot of,
I think it's stenosis,
spinal stenosis for,
for years,
you know what I mean?
Source.
Do you do any decompression?
I do a little bit here and there.
Whenever I can get to the chiropractors
I'm doing some or you know,
it's like I said it's been bad for
years.
Have you seen that thing that you hook
up to your neck and yet came from a
doorway
stretch it?
No,
I did that same thing with a rolled up
towel or bang from the doorway and it
helps mind tremendously,
but I got mine I'm sure from fighting,
but then also like I'll lay on my back
at night for like two weeks.
My neck will be all know.
Isn't it crazy?
You're a professional fighter.
You fuck up your back watching youtube
videos for sure.
But everyone's doing it,
man.
That's all we do is take the whole
working.
People's necks are changing.
It's terrible
if it wasn't for like,
you know,
being in awareness that I have now for
like my neck and neck injuries,
just seeing a lot of things.
I'm like trying to posture up and just
seeing shit because I'm just,
I'm always like this.
Always,
always hurting.
So you know,
it's been one thing after another four
years and that's actually leading into
this,
you know,
this accident with this injury,
try to keep this mike closer like this
noble to y'all.
So are you.
How old are you now?
Daniel,
I am 33,
34.
I'm at that age where you forget how old
you are.
Yeah.
So I'll be 34 and nine July.
Well your,
you're healthy and you know,
the ability to recuperate from something
that's that devastating that quickly
shows what good of shape you're in.
That must have a big impact on,
on your rehab process.
Right.
Does,
it does mean a regular person that has
that kind of injury probably is not
going to bounce back like that.
Not as quickly and being like I said,
being an athlete has helped me
tremendously.
I mean,
well my neck,
Korean obviously as strong as it was,
the,
you know,
the damage would have been worse.
But uh,
being able to bounce back was been,
you know,
being young,
being able to.
I put my body through so much that this
is.
Yeah.
Compared to what has been through.
So yeah,
being young definitely helped me and
trying to keep that,
that,
that time away,
but you know,
so how will you know when you get back
in there?
Are you wrestling yet?
Yeah,
wrestling,
doing everything.
You wrestle them,
Breslin I've wrestled.
Yeah,
wow.
I'm nervous about getting your neck
yanked on.
Uh,
I was nervous before.
Right.
But now I'm just getting confident with
getting my neck strong,
making sure I don't do the stupid moves
I've been doing the caused the injury.
So,
um,
my next step is just being clear.
BNC by a doctor,
a neurologist.
Yes.
He can fight.
Sign off.
Let's get back to business.
So,
and house bound toward treating all this
great.
Uh,
I can't say anything negative about them
because they've always done nothing but
help me out in situations so,
you know,
I've been with them
or sometime you know,
and uh,
two times world champion tomorrow too if
y'all motherfuckers didn't know.
But uh,
yeah,
they've always,
they've always been fair to me,
you know,
that's great.
Obviously you've always had problems
here and there,
but I've never really had any major,
you know,
loved Scott Coker.
I do too.
He's a good dude.
So I always been good to me.
So it's been really good.
I hear nothing but good things to it and
how they treat people like guys who have
gone over there said it's a,
it's just a huge relief to get treated
with respect.
You know,
like they were a little nervous about
going over there.
Right,
right.
You know,
a lot of people will always ask them,
hey,
would you want it?
I'm like,
Eh,
this is home for me.
You know what I mean?
Like,
man,
the ideal for everybody would be bell
to.
It gets to the same state as the UFC.
The same level.
That would be ideal.
That would help.
Like if you see Gennady Golovkin
fighting Canelo Alvarez,
you don't give a fuck if it's golden boy
versus Bob Arum.
Nobody that they want to see champions
go after it.
That's,
that's what everybody wants to see.
Ultimately that's what I would like to
see across the board.
You know,
I mean I don't think it harms anybody.
I think it helps everybody.
Competition is definitely getting better
for everybody.
It's better for the athletes for sure.
You know,
and the more money that gets thrown
around and the more promoted.
I mean,
if,
if a superstar emerges from beltour tour
that's at the same level that Rhonda
was,
or connor is or something like that
would be amazing.
That's great for everybody.
For everybody.
And you know,
there's a possibility there too.
I mean,
Michael Venom pages,
he's getting a lot of mainstream press.
People were paying attention to him now
because the other crazy shit.
He doesn't matter.
We need more of that.
I thought he actually retired from him
in a box for awhile,
like retired from the a box to
something.
Nothing.
You know what man,
dude like that probably will retire and
unretired just for the press,
you know,
just seems to be the thing that happens
a lot.
Speaking of retiring and retiring
Joe Shell and back to mma,
I know you competed in the high rollers
event this weekend,
which by the way,
Eddie Bravo told me he was so high.
He thought he was going to jail.
He told me,
he goes,
I was convinced I was going to jail.
It was so paranoid.
That was such a cool event.
The event for people don't know what the
fuck we're talking about.
So it was an event put on that cell and
a big lawn on my buddy's,
they called the high rollers and it's
cannabis infused Jujitsu tournament is
what they call day.
What are those two dudes that's slapped
each other and then they smoked a joint
together?
The lapd there something between and
then they stepped out with a joint.
I mean it was good though.
Before every match,
everybody smoked.
They smoked together.
The whole event.
There was no alcohol.
The Bible Super Chill.
They played like hip hop in the
background fall.
It was like kind of press star studded
event.
It was really fucking cool as it is by
far the coolest martial arts event I've
ever been to.
It was the
shout out to that Dj man.
He did like eight hours straight playing
the same song,
like only twice paid twice a month.
Uh,
we don't really,
I don't think he had bought it.
Was it?
It's a weird connection.
Marijuana with Jujitsu and it's always
been there.
And people that don't know,
like people that don't smoke weed,
like I have to tell them that please.
Jeff Glover
and his opponent smoking weed.
It's hilarious.
Man is really,
really fun and that they're doing that
man,
but I like it was a real cool event and
it was real cool Jujitsu and we'd have
always been connected for as long as
I've been doing Jujitsu.
People smoked pot in the parking lot and
then went and enrolled.
That's still do kickboxing apparently is
the same way you practice focus.
But I always found that I'm not good at
learning when I'm high or maybe I get
too high and I can't learn like,
like some Oh,
show me something and I'm not sure where
to put my legs.
I'm like,
what do I do?
Step over here would have put my right
foot.
What?
Yeah,
I find that a bit,
but when I'm rolling,
if I'm rolling high then it just,
you just get into that zone and
if you know,
like when they say like,
uh,
if you take it,
when you study for a test,
you're sucking on peppermint and then
the day of the test you take pepper.
You suck on pepper.
You supposed to help you remember?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Like that's Kinda how it is
with,
uh,
with martial arts for me anyway,
like I'm high as fuck and I'm kinda like
just a programming into my deep
subconscious or whatever.
That's my thought.
Maybe you think smoking all the time
when you try and then smoking,
not smoking when you perform,
do you think that has a,
like a positive or negative effect?
Uh,
I don't know.
I don't really.
Well,
well let me ask you this,
if that was the first time I said we're
not testing for weed,
you could fight high as fuck.
What would you do that smoke that day?
I wouldn't smoke probably 10 minutes
before a lot of shit going on in my
head.
This is cool.
But like,
yeah,
it's a lot of money on the line.
Well it's also,
you know,
the consequences are a lot different,
zig zagging a lot different when kicks
and punches are being thrown.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Well remember when Nate Diaz or nick
rather fought Gomi?
Nick Fargo me home.
Well,
I mean,
I know nick and I,
if you asked him that question,
you'd be like,
Oh,
have you spoken to right there?
And like he would for sure 100 percent.
I bet he would fight better probably.
Yeah,
not a fan of it.
You're not a fan of fighting.
Hi.
No,
no,
no fault.
One time.
What happened?
Well,
for once,
for once I went through the crowd
instead of the,
the walkway.
That's what I do it
like you.
You're supposed to come out.
I was at Shark Bites and uh,
you'd come out and then you go at an l
shape and go straight to the cage.
Came out the ushers always fuck that
shit up though.
That's happened like every time he tried
to walk out the cage the wrong way.
Like,
no,
the other one.
Anyway,
so I came out just crowd sitting there
and just beeline straight to the crowd.
Excuse me.
Stepping up to the cage,
like stepped over the fence.
Check me out.
Got It.
Now I'm like,
ah,
I don't remember.
Shock fights and the,
that was a bud brotzmann thing.
He's a buddy of mine.
Bullshit.
Yeah.
He was one of the original guys that are
on King of the cage.
Was it?
Yeah.
Then didn't get involved in shark
fights.
Yeah.
Somebody.
Did they have something to do with like
fight as well?
I don't know.
So maybe there's a few people involved.
So it was a good car though.
I had a ga podell.
They had a show.
Could you want to fuck with a bunch of
people know?
Hmm.
So what was it like fighting?
Hi.
Well for me at the time,
that was my biggest event and almost
fighting a Karen,
Deborah Gideon.
So it was the biggest name I had fought
to me it was like that.
Fuck.
You know what I mean?
I just was kind of overwhelmed.
I wasn't a Jujitsu.
I didn't know much about you.
Just to actually,
the whole fight was weird because on
Monday I separated.
My arm are separated my shoulder.
Wednesday they called me for the fight.
Saturday
fought for years to like,
I guess I'll get high for this.
Right.
You separated show like what?
Like separation,
like a separated shoulder.
Torn muscle.
No,
no,
no.
Um,
yeah,
up in the um,
I don't know what the fuck you asked me.
Did he love him?
Yeah,
well we got it like bandaged up,
got to work in,
fought with it.
He didn't fight,
would've been bandaged up,
but the next few days kind of build on
it.
I said worked on as much as I can.
Went out there.
Uh,
it was in Texas,
fought and uh,
yeah,
it was just for me.
It was weird.
Like I said,
one decision,
uh,
like I said at first round he had threw
a bunch of like lego blocks.
Yeah,
he's a serious spookseekers leg lock.
That's what I was saying.
Like,
hi,
I don't know,
I just want to get out of here.
So it was,
it was a bad thing for me.
So one I'm done fighting,
I'm done.
I was like,
I'm cool.
Have you ever fought?
Hi?
Uh,
I mean,
I'm sure I've fought at spar high all
the time.
What's your feeling about that?
I think it like a for this Jujitsu
tournament,
you know,
Jujitsu is not my strong suit obviously.
And so for me,
that was my first Jiu Jitsu tournament
and we just put on the gay like about a
month ago when Matt told me about the
things you should do it and Micky Gall I
trained with everyday and uh,
him and Bomba and we like,
all right,
fuck it,
we'll do it.
So we start putting on the g and the,
that was a,
I didn't want to make a fool of myself.
So being high and having that like
pressure,
like not being completely comfortable,
I think it was different.
But like in a kickboxing fight I could
probably be drunk and still be pretty
comfortable with.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that think that
I'm one of them to think that marijuana
is a performance enhancing drug.
I don't think so.
Yeah.
On a certain.
On certain levels,
certain levels I think you can fuck you
up but.
But it's,
if you get the dose right,
I think you puts you in a zone in a
comfortable zone.
Right.
And I think a lot of them for
performance,
like how well it's gonna increase your
performance is not being super stressed
out over bullshit the week.
And that's where I find the most
benefit.
Like when I would quit smoking weed for
a couple of days before the fight,
that was when it's like now is when I
need it the most.
That was when the most stressed out when
I had the most anxiety that I have the
hungriest they can,
you know,
I was like,
this sucks,
you know,
like in displays and just relax.
I think that helps.
Hey Man.
How you doing?
Any cryo therapy or anything to reduce
swelling?
A little.
Like I said,
I was doing a little bit with uh,
the um,
the.
I'm drawing a blank,
the chiropractor that I was going to,
but I haven't done much of it.
But that's one thing I really wanted to
get into because of the swelling a lot.
Like I said,
a lot of it,
it's went down over the,
over the time.
But body feels amazing after that crab.
Yeah,
dude,
I'm a big fan.
And you do it like super doses of cbd
though too.
Yeah,
a lot of CBD.
A lot part of that.
Some of that in that bag you gave me.
Yeah,
check that out.
That's some flavor rec stuff that a flat
can't stop.
Crazy shirt in there.
Quite a few.
Can I take just wondering,
I'm like,
is he a medium or large and extra large?
No,
just broke as fuck.
I put large.
Isn't there?
Perfect.
That was perfect.
So strength for you joe.
What js?
It's a company called flavor to CBD
Company.
I've been working with red pen,
so like medicated drops.
I get it gives you like a certain dose
every time you click it.
Oh,
I've been using um,
you ever heard that company Jambo?
They just sent me some cbd.
A rub on.
Holy Shit.
Is that work for you?
Fuck yeah.
Two thousand milligrams cbd rub on.
I told you this sciatic pains but fuck
with me or the last week or so and uh,
I rub it on my hip like it's like my ass
muscle right over like right here.
That's where like it travels down and I
rubbed that shit on before I go to
that has these,
a medicated patches you can use to have
roll ons that you could use evidence
solve stuff.
And uh,
I just feel like I smoked so much weed
with cbd in it all the time that it
don't,
it doesn't seem to work for me.
I don't notice it,
you know?
And then they have vision droppers.
I use that like crazy.
Yeah.
Maybe you just got too much of a
tolerance.
Why?
I just think of you.
If you smoke weed constantly,
there's cbd and everything.
You're hitting both.
So like when,
when my coach who's like 65 and never
smokes weed and I give him,
put that shit on him,
he's like,
oh my God,
my elbow feels crazy.
I'll get you some of that Jambo Shit.
It's better than anything I've ever used
before.
They have two versions.
They have a thousand milligrams in 2000
milligram and I put that 2000 milligram
and it's got like a menthol in it.
So you feel it in your skin,
like woo heats up.
Only time I've really ever filling that
is like using it on my neck,
like using on my neck and I've used it
on my hand to where I liked the achiness
does the achiness goes
away,
but on my neck as well,
I felt the most like up in the pain,
but I put this of CBD vaporizers in.
Then there's cbd bath bomb.
We used that before my buddy's fight,
the day of the fight.
We dropped it in the a and the hot tub
CBD bomb.
Some fucking monsters out there that are
trying to make this illegal and it's
pharmaceutical.
Those guys.
Fuck those guys.
So scary that someone would do that.
They would try to spend money to try to
make this stuff illegal and while
they're doing that,
they legalized like the fucking gmo
synthetic version,
which is like actually killing
seriously.
Fuck those people or fentanyl.
That shit's killing.
Everybody killed Prince.
It killed David.
Bowie had killed.
Who the fuck else are?
They killed it.
Killed it.
Killed a bunch of people.
This year Tom Petty Killed Tom Petty
too.
Did he killed David Bowie or something?
Killed David Bowie.
Who knows?
What's the ball?
That's a.
it's a cbd bath bomb.
Dang.
You just drop that in.
That's it.
It's fucking not fucking around.
Legit.
Good time.
I really feel like a rub on effect from
CBD is soak in.
One of those is really never did.
The bathroom is good and it's fun to
watch you drop it in and I'll got a lot
of shit right?
Some stuff,
Joe.
I got some good little,
uh,
you know,
to Chili's and Adam.
Woo.
Good stuff.
Exciting.
Live acts.
Got It all.
And this is also my.
Take this on my international flights.
Allegedly the key is illegal.
It's illegal,
but it's when you put the vape pen and
do it,
it looks like a car key so you can just
walk right in security.
Oh that's crazy.
I'm in the bathroom.
Say screw the cap on from,
from us.
He put it in there.
And Man.
And these are these candy.
So my complaint about the candy thing is
if they're going to have like um,
those are cbd with thc wants to.
And if you're going to have thc,
like super potent candy,
they shouldn't taste so fucking good
because I'll eat the whole bag.
You know what I mean?
Like who's going to eat?
Just one.
That's very good.
That's watermelon.
Watermelon bags.
Ambulance.
Yeah.
This is watermelon.
It's like your belt.
Super Lucky.
Do check your shit.
The Shit.
Look at this thing.
I love it.
And then I think it has like A.
There's three different settings.
Repeat or value burning these kids
today.
Oh,
you got to turn it on five times.
Click it.
Find on to the other side.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five.
Boom.
Nope.
That's the heat up to work.
A joke.
Fucking it up there.
Job.
You got it.
You got to go on.
Maybe it had to heat up.
There it goes.
Burn it.
How was the ballot tours?
Drug testing policy standard.
We don't have like the additional,
uh,
you saw the random tests.
But I get tested before or after every
fight.
I've been tested most of my fights.
I know that.
Yeah.
So.
And I've had people talk shit like,
ah,
they don't tell us,
well I don't know what you're talking
about the test after fights,
but obviously there's a big difference
between that and hey it's four weeks
out,
wake up,
6:30
in the morning,
would even up to Daniel here,
Piston Cup,
look at that stair or it's crazy.
I mean they,
they have lost a lot of people off the
roster in the UFC.
The really crazy thing is the body's
changing people.
You weren't sure,
you know,
everybody passed the test when they were
doing it on the way in day,
but then you're looking at their bodies
changed.
Like whoa.
So many of them just shriveled up and
they just looked totally different.
And their performances are different
mindsets,
different guys that were just
unstoppable.
And so they came in.
It's like you're on like a six fight,
losing streak.
Crazy dropped two weight classes.
Anybody who says it's steroids doesn't
work as they're crazy fucking mind.
They're not taking it for fun.
They're not going all the way down to
Tijuana and buying this shit because
it's fun to get to do something on the
weekend.
So do you feel like you got a new lease
on life?
Um,
I'd do,
man.
Right now I'm just grinding,
like fully focused on getting back into
the cage,
like,
you know,
having,
having what happened to me and being in
a position that I'm in,
I don't really have too many things to
go back to them.
So you know,
having a new lease on life really isn't
how I would say it is,
it's just what it is.
I'm just focused on the next step,
you know what I mean?
The next step in my career,
the next step in the path and what I've
been going through,
you know,
it's always just something for me.
So no,
I wouldn't say it's a new lease of life,
but just a new chapter.
But you must feel very fortunate that
you can recover from that.
I do,
I do.
It's amazing story.
I love hearing that
is,
it just sucks.
You know what I mean?
It sucks to be in this position,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm here,
I'm talking to you,
talking to this guy,
walking around.
So I'm blessed more than,
than anything,
but this is just fired me up to just get
sick on,
you know what I mean?
So you got to feel pretty fucking
unstoppable after I go fly into the air
slamming champion before this shit.
And you come back like,
what's going to stop?
Yeah,
that's the goal.
Get another belt,
get back,
get another belt.
Show people.
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not done.
Not done at all.
You know?
So uh,
yeah.
I'm even still riding.
Are you fucking savage?
Jesus Christ.
Just say one 76 the other day,
dude.
I'd be an h one.
The real one.
A real hummer.
I'd be in one of those bitches and I'd
ride in the middle of it.
Figure out a way to.
If we put the steering wheel in the
middle,
I don't want to be on either side and
strapped me in with a race harness and
put fucking airbags everywhere.
I want this thing to be like an
inflatable bath toy,
but I'm an.
I'm an
adrenaline junkie,
so although to do anything,
you know,
I shouldn't be riding obviously,
but uh,
you know,
I need something to study my mind.
So like I said,
training training has been going
something I got back into riding,
something I got back into and it's
pushing me to like move forward with
that because.
How long was it before you wrote again?
I probably started riding again maybe
about a month and a half years.
What?
About a month ago?
About a month ago.
A month ago.
Okay.
Not a month end.
So five months after the injury?
Probably about a month.
If you did a month after an injury,
like this dude is fucking crazy.
Get barely walk.
That's some shit I would try to.
I mean I would definitely try it.
But what do you think makes you such an
adrenaline junkie?
I don't know.
Even right before all my fights.
So like it's just been that way.
Like I would always ride a lot before my
fights because I had to release,
you know,
all the adrenaline and all the pent up
like anxiety,
anxiety going on and that's just how
I've always been.
I've always wanted to see what was it
like to kill yourself,
you know?
What was it like that?
No,
you know what I mean?
Like adrenaline wise,
what was it like to do something fun,
exciting to push the limit,
get on the APP,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
That sounds very different than I didn't
mean it like that.
You don't want to.
Fighters that are liked.
I mean Diego corrals.
He died in a motorcycle accident.
Paul Williams,
you know,
he got fucked up.
There's so many fighters that have
gotten into motorcycles for that very
reason,
but it's not just motorcycles.
I mean I've done until all type of shit.
Like what else?
I mean,
I love diving waters when one of my
favorite things.
Oceans,
one of my favorite things to do.
No,
I've never been in a situation whereby
the diary thing,
but you know,
I want to do skydiving.
I want to do rock climb and I want to do
all of these
show shillings on my page.
He and Joe are on the same page.
I don't even like roller coasters to
drag me on it the first time.
Then I'm like,
we're going again.
To that point,
I'm like,
no,
fuck that.
You ride bikes a little bit,
but I want to go the down at the ranch
with coldwell riding with them,
but they make fun of me because I'll go
like 60,
like 60.
Then it starts getting like,
oh no.
It must be cool.
Cowboy example will be fucking going
down the highway 90 with his hat off,
like resizing his hat,
you know?
No hands 90 down the highway or snapping
pictures
of us while he's riding.
Oh Jesus.
I don't want.
Isn't that
for sure.
I love that dude.
I don't want them to get hurt.
I don't want to hear that.
Yeah,
fuck what?
He's good at it.
I guess.
I'm sure he is good at fighting too,
but it's fucking dangerous.
Just like you should dot your I's.
Cross your t's or 90 on the highway.
Fuck that.
Yeah.
He's a perfect example of a legit
adrenaline junkies.
One hundred percent.
Yeah,
100 percent.
One hundred percent.
I guess just some people once.
I guess fighting is a big part of it.
Like once you've experienced the highs
of fighting,
I guess the,
the lows of regular life or just too
fucking boring?
Is that what it is,
man?
Imagine.
I feel like you would get.
I would definitely mammon thought about
retiring,
but when I stopped fighting I think
that's what really bothered me because
I'm addicted to like not the adrenaline
side of the lake.
The challenge like the you can't do this
like me versus the world like that.
That really gets me going.
I think if I didn't have that when I'm
older,
I'd be pretty pissed off you versus the
world.
Like how so?
Uh,
like,
or like even me versus a man versus man,
like one on one,
like no other.
It's just,
you're the only one that you can,
you can count on in that scenario I
guess.
But like that,
that personal challenge is what drives
me and fuels me.
And that's why I think in my career,
the fights that I wasn't supposed to
win,
we're always the ones that I really
showed up for it because that Jen,
that,
that hit me where it was,
if I was supposed,
supposed to,
when everyone thought I was going to win
for some on some level,
I would not show up the same way.
Very common.
That's very common.
Yeah.
A lot of guys,
when,
when they think it's going to be an easy
fight,
they can't get up.
They don't.
They just have this weird.
And it's weird
because like you don't know,
your coaches won't let you not trained
that way.
Like you train hard for the fight,
you know that something about the thing
in your head doesn't click or it
doesn't,
don't go after.
Yeah.
It's like the thing that everybody hates
the most about before a fight that
discomfort and anxiety and just fuck,
why am I doing this?
Fuck.
That is what is your friend when you're
in there?
Yeah.
It's the fights were guiding extent.
That's what fucking drowns you at the
same time.
Because it'd be people like fucking
their whole campus,
perfect.
And as soon as they walk out in front of
that crowd,
it's like who the coach is,
like,
who the fuck is this?
What the fuck's going on?
But don't you think that that's always
that kind of person,
like a guy like you doesn't have that.
There's not,
that's not a thing that you experience,
you know,
I mean there's the type of people that
crumble or usually like the guys who are
just murderers in the gym and then for
whatever reason,
under the bright lights they falter,
but they rarely rise.
Like those guys rarely win the big
fights that they're not supposed to win.
That's not,
they're not the same psychological
makeup.
So like something about the challenge or
the unknown to some people it just
overwhelms them.
Whereas other people,
whatever their psychological is,
that challenge is what fires them up and
gets them excited.
Yeah.
It's weird,
right?
Consistency is the hard part.
And longevity for fighters in general.
The curriculum,
that's what makes floyd mayweather so
impressive to me is for him to be at the
top of the game for so long and can make
all the money and continue to be at the
top of the game and still do that.
I mean versus like,
you know,
the guys that blow up and then Jon Jones
has trouble,
they don't know how to deal with the
fame for him.
Connor throwing shit through bus
windows.
Like it's hard to stay balanced and
consistent through that whole mental
thing.
The biggest one of my biggest thing has
been,
you know,
the mental part of fighting,
getting to the top,
being pushed back down,
you know,
just dealing with that as a fighter has
put a lot of stress on them.
Like,
you know,
every time that I got into the cage,
like had thought or how I acted.
A performance.
Yeah.
So you,
you did some work with vinny shoreman,
right?
Yep.
How did that help?
A vinny helped me a lot for a,
worked with him for I think three years,
two or three years.
And I find that I'm tell everybody
beneath Germans a hypnotist whose been
on the show a couple times.
Actually I was the one that had told you
about the bottom up on this phone.
Shit,
someone wants credit.
I made you have any.
Um,
he has me.
It was a trip.
Right?
Wow.
This is real.
It really worked for me.
And then,
uh,
I find that as I've grown,
I think just like any technique you get
better at it and has it needs time to
lay,
kinda resonate inside of you.
And I feel,
I mean I haven't worked with them in
over a year and a,
I still am figuring out like,
oh that was the fuck he was talking
about.
Or like this is leanne starts to sink
in.
So I think it's been,
the mental game is a huge,
a huge asset.
Do you ever work with a sports
psychologist or a hypnotist or anything
like that?
I mean I've worked a little bit with a
guy named will back in Florida.
This was some years ago,
but something I've always wanted to
dabble in.
Something I've wanted to explore.
I haven't really got a chance to do a
lot of things,
but that's one thing I've always,
like I said,
the mental part is been key to me,
so I've always wanted to do
it might be a good thing to help you
during your recovery too,
you know,
to just really concentrate on recovery
and really concentrate on the parts of
your body that need
be fixed and you need to reach out to
the right people to get the right,
you know,
um,
help as far as like,
you know,
people to talk to as far as like that.
I don't really know anybody like that.
Vinny shoreman to the rescue.
You?
Yeah,
he'll,
he's probably listening.
He'll do it over skype to you do it over
a fucking face time.
And the of used to hypnotize me over
facetime all the time and then get on
fight day.
He would call me and like we'd be
backstage.
He'll be back in the states in October.
Yeah.
So
I'll look it up.
I'll make the connection.
I would definitely look into that would
definitely like.
But you've been using the,
a lion's mane.
Mushrooms,
two minutes.
Yeah.
I send them that video and started
talking to him about it.
When I found out about what happened to
him,
you know,
it was like,
I'm sure not as bad as he was going
through,
but like we were just going to walk
again.
Oh,
if Dan was in a horrible accident and
then every time I talked to him he would
just be like real like,
Nah,
fuck them.
It's going to happen.
Fuck that.
I'm like,
alright,
you need to take this lion's mane.
Mushroom.
He needs with these core to set
mushrooms,
take all the flavor of cbd that you can
get some other mushrooms is good for
your brain.
You'll be cool.
And uh,
I mean,
look at it.
Look what I did.
Oh Joe Joe.
Walking around and hearing that you're
sparring and hitting the bag and heating
pads.
Yeah,
I mean all these things put together.
It's just what's given me back.
So it's nothing's impossible.
I mean,
I can prove that nothing's impossible
and shit,
you know,
doing it,
like you said,
even the lion's mane and the different
CBDS I've been taken and just getting my
body back to like feeling good mentally
feeling good,
just everything's working.
Like in steps,
so little steps at a time.
Basically every day by day.
So we'd say like 80 percent now I'll
give you 75.
Seventy five is good,
you know,
75 minutes you can get to 100,
like I'm running.
You know what I'm saying?
That wasn't one of my big goals was like
buy in six months,
I want to be running,
set a goal,
started running,
boom.
I'm a guy who couldn't walk.
Exactly.
So that's awesome.
It's,
it's,
I don't know,
it gives me an a.
every time I think about it,
the reason why I stopped just because
every time I have to talk about it,
I get into mental thought of it in the
process of going,
laying in the bed,
not be able to feel shit to,
you know,
dragging your foot after you're walking
with a walker to be able to pull up your
pants.
Now it's crazy.
It is fucking crazy.
You know what I mean?
And it just,
it keeps me.
It keeps me humble enough to just talk
about the situation and love it.
Love Life.
That's a beautiful story man.
I love hearing things like that.
People recovering from things because
it's just,
it makes you appreciate the fact that
you are all healthy every time anything
goes wrong in your life.
It's an opportunity to appreciate what
it's like when things go right and if
you can get back to where you were and
you'll have a new perspective.
I do for sure.
For sure.
Are you fucking with that lion's mane
stuff too?
Yeah.
My how often you take it.
I was taking it every day.
I made a bunch of capsules with lion's
mane and a quarter.
So you made the capsules yourself.
You can buy it on Amazon little capsule
machine.
Make 100 capsules a little concoction.
They're nice.
So when I saw on your,
your show,
I'm Paul stamets was talking about how
the,
uh,
I think it was cte that you guys were
talking about how the,
the lion's Mane helps a final note on
the for repairs it or if it just helps
like the find a way around blockages or
whatever with neural tissue.
Nerve tissue.
And I was like,
Daniel,
I hit him up with a right.
No,
that,
lion's mane stuff is miraculous.
I mean there's,
it's amazing that more people don't know
about it and that more people aren't
talking about it,
but anybody that's involved in contact
sports and the athletes that are getting
hit and they're getting their cage
rattled a lot.
They should be taking that stuff all the
time.
Yeah.
And CBD as well,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean,
I just look at it like the business that
we're in is really dangerous and like if
you know that there's something that you
guys could get punchy,
right,
or guys lose their chin or have problems
like performing on fight night or
whatever,
like if you can,
if you could take cbd to be better for
swelling,
you can take lines made of repair,
the concussions and shit that we're
getting constantly.
Like I just think you're kind of stupid
if you're not actively trying to figure
out a solution to all these problems.
Have you ever fuck with Kratom?
I never.
Not really.
I know people that have.
I've,
I was um,
I was hanging out with Simon rex
yesterday and he was telling me like
some awesome stories about people that
were addicted to opiates.
They got off of it with Kratom,
Aka dirt nasty.
So good.
That's so funny,
dude.
That's an awesome dude.
He's a good dude.
I,
uh,
I took eight,
created eight pills yesterday,
which most of the time I was taking two
and then I took four and then yesterday
I took eight.
Now I get it.
That stuff makes you high as fuck when
you take eight.
My whole body felt weird.
I was like pretending to be sober.
I was walking around and pretend to be
sober,
but not like a drunk.
Not,
not like reaction time,
like almost knocked something off the
counter.
I caught it real quick.
It's like everything's normal.
Like your body moves good,
but you're like,
Woo.
You feel weird.
You feel like you're under the
physically.
Mentally.
It's very nice.
It's like,
yeah,
it gives you a body buzz,
but it's,
it's great at alleviating anxiety.
Like it makes you really chill.
It's weird.
It's just like puts you in this nice
headspace where you just like,
ugh.
Like everything's calm.
I think the idea is that it fills up
these opium receptors and that's what,
uh,
what people that have had real problems
with opiates.
That's why they like it.
Because even if you're fucked up on it,
you're not fucked up.
You fucked up like,
Woo.
I feel something.
Something crazy is going on.
And I was taking eight and my buddy
Chris Bell,
he's the guy who directed that a bigger,
stronger,
faster documentary.
He had a real problem with opiates.
He got a pretty serious,
a hip injury,
how to get a hip replacement surgery and
was in massive and when he has a serious
arthritis,
like a genetic arthritis,
and when he got his hip replaced and got
on pain pills,
he got hooked bad in the middle of
making a documentary about prescription
drugs,
which is crazy.
In the middle of it,
he got hooked himself,
just total random,
you know,
synchronicity.
And he takes 10.
He takes 10 of those,
so he takes two more than I took it
yesterday for like four hours.
I was walking around like this,
but there's no real side effects in
comparison to the other stuff.
No,
no real side effects.
After that last man standing tournament,
I'm with Laura,
had three fights in one night.
My,
I had like super bad chest contusion of
my chest is still there years later,
the swelling and swelling of my sternum.
And uh,
it would pinch off nerves running down
my shoulder.
And then I think it actually pinched off
the nerve root,
which is when I started doing the,
um,
the decompression with the chiropractor
and so my left side started like,
getting,
like,
it was noticeably getting smaller,
like it was the muscle atrophies because
you don't know that I didn't know.
You might know what Joe,
you know,
everything is that the nerve root
actually feeds them the muscle and
allows it to grow without,
once that's fucked up,
then your muscle won't grow anymore.
It's when you atrophy and shit,
it's very difficult to get it to grow
back to if you don't catch it quickly.
Right.
And,
uh,
did you have a problem and get into grow
back or do you catch it quick?
Well,
I think when we started doing the
decompression and all that stuff,
it worked.
Um,
I mean it grew back I think,
um,
but the,
the pain that I was feeling from all the
shit I kept,
I kept getting Vicodin,
prescription Vikatin in Norco and uh,
you're literally in pain.
So I would take the medicine.
But,
um,
after like two months,
like I looked at my kitchen counter and
there was just empty pill bottles,
like everywhere.
And I noticed that I was like really
fucking aggressive and like short and
like I just stopped right away when I,
when I realized that,
but I could totally see how that would
be.
That could become a,
an addictive thing for sure.
I was there manning,
you really need it,
you know,
it wasn't like I was like trying to get
fucked up.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm in pain and take a pill.
And then,
uh,
did you go to a doctor and get it looked
at?
Yeah,
I went to.
What did they say about your sternum?
Uh,
they said that there was nothing wrong
with it and went to the hospital twice.
I woke up,
uh,
America woke up screaming and shaking
from the pain and went to the doctor,
the hospital,
and they did an x ray.
And so there's nothing wrong with that.
And I'm like,
look at the swelling.
It looked like a tennis ball.
And they said that it was in our
cartilage or between the ribs or had
gotten some sort of confusion,
you know,
somebody gets a hit and elbow and there
had swells up that mine was doing that
under the rib or under the sternum
plates or some shit.
So there's this constant pressure.
I just started taking advil,
like it was going out of style and then
that would make the swelling go down and
then I wasn't in pain anymore.
And the problem that I was having with
the Vicodin was it's not an anti
inflammatory,
so it did nothing for the,
for the actual cause of the pain.
And I was just eating fucking vicodin
like crazy.
So,
um,
and then,
uh,
yeah,
but not,
I pretty much eat.
I take advil every day regardless for my
knees hurting or my toes are hurting.
Or like just years of not supposed to
fuck with that stuff every day.
It's not good to do the honest gut
health.
Right.
That'll help.
I mean,
in Kimchi helps to probiotics Kombucha.
It just,
it ruins your gut health and it causes
inflammation.
This is what my friend Cameron Hanes who
runs ultra marathons,
he was taking 800 milligrams a day,
sometimes twice a day and a because he
was in pain all the time because he runs
fucking dude runs a marathon every day
on Saturday.
This Saturday coming up,
he's running for 24 hours and his goal
is 120 miles in 24 hours.
I mean,
he's a fucking maniac.
So this dude's always in pain.
And uh,
I had Dr Rhonda Patrick on.
She was explaining about how
nonsteroidal antiinflammatories like
Ibuprofen actually cause inflammation
because they fuck up your gut bacteria
and they fuck up your body's ability to
process information and it causes pain.
So he listened and there's connections
to stroke and all sorts of other
problems.
So he gets off of it and all his pain
went away.
His pain was caused in part by the fact
that he was taking this stuff for his
pain,
which is a terrible,
ridiculous vicious cycle.
What's APP for how long?
Straight was he taking?
He was taking it for years.
For years.
Yeah,
he will because he's been running
forever.
He's been doing marathons and ultra
brand 238 miles last year.
The,
you know the mole APP to 30,
which is just the same.
Yeah,
we'll have to even possible it takes
three days,
three fucking days.
What's really crazy is you have to.
The first day you woke up the next day,
another 24 hours of reading.
So there's a type of mindset that you
have to have to be able to do something
like that.
That's just super human.
You have to be able to just every step,
left foot,
right foot,
right foot and agony and pain.
All your toenails are falling off.
Everything's in seeing them post
pictures of nasty fucking feet.
All fucked up.
Yeah.
What's crazy is a woman beat everybody
by more than 10 hours.
A woman who I had on her name is
courtney doe.
Walter,
she beat everybody by 22 miles.
She was 22 miles ahead of the second
place.
Dude,
it's unbelievable.
She's a fucking animal.
She slept for one minute and three days.
One Minute for a minute.
Sorry.
Twenty two miles come up.
I don't think steroids help in that
world.
I think in that world those people are
just,
it's just mental.
I really,
I really don't think it helps.
And then they'll get paid for it a
little bit.
They get sponsors and shit.
Cam doesn't get paid.
He had a sponsors under armour sponsors
them and you know,
but not really.
It's just because they're animals.
I know every step I'd be like thinking
about what am I doing this for?
Well it's also your use to psychotic
interactions with other people
in short amount of time.
Like you used to like 20 minutes
description.
Chaos.
I mean dude,
that last man standing,
it was one of my favorite events I've
ever been to.
I fucking loved it.
I don't want you to ever do it again
because I love you fighting fucking four
times in a night.
Oh Man,
I kinda want to do it again.
It's crazy.
There's something about doing that,
you know,
you're doing something special and,
and uh,
you know,
epic like that was,
that was my man the last man standing
the tournament.
That was like my main focus after the,
after I knocked out Simon Marcus and
then I guess after a beat,
after the first two fights going into
the third one,
like I'm pretty sure I wasn't going to
beat our two most to beat up,
but I was just had this crazy buzz about
knowing that I was doing something
special like this was really fucking
cool,
but I would love to do it again.
I think that's how those people will
feel when they're running those crazy
ultra marathon.
They know they're about to do something
insane.
It'd been a regular fight.
Is Insane.
To regular fights in a night is insane.
Three irregular fights in the night
against worldclass kickboxers and then
the first fight you got to go for rounds
because after three rounds it was a
draw.
What in the fuck man,
good notify.
Had to do that shit right now if you get
excited to hear you talk about it.
I liked.
I've always loved tournaments.
I've always wanted to be in like a day
tournament like that should be dope.
Now you're making your move back to mma
because kickboxing is just not what it
should be.
I think we both feel that kickboxing is
one of my favorite things to watch.
I'm a giant fan of it and for whatever
reason it is just not caught on in
America the same way boxing has or the
same way.
And my man
Smith and I've spent my whole,
well I've been doing this since I was
15.
I'm 34.
So all of that time I've been thinking
about this same question and then like
I'm just,
you know,
it is what it is.
Yeah.
It's like you can't hold onto it
anymore,
at least not for me.
The sport is going to grow,
it's going to keep,
keep doing good.
And I hope that that continues,
but for me,
I need to do,
uh,
keep,
keep progressing,
so to speak.
That is a
did.
Here's what it is.
I mean,
that's the best way to put it because
there's no way we're gonna fix it,
but I don't understand,
you know,
I mean,
I really,
really don't understand.
I fucking love watching kickboxing and
when people tell me about how they love
boxing,
I'm like,
that's great.
Boxing is great.
I love boxing to kickboxing is way
better than boxing.
That extra level of,
you know,
thrown in kicks and knees and especially
if you go to Moitai elbows and clench.
It's just,
it's a wilder,
crazier striking sport and I just don't
understand it.
I mean,
when I watch you fight or Kevin fied
or you know,
Kevin Ross or Georgia Petrosian John
Wayne part,
like,
how the fuck would you not want to watch
that?
But it's so exciting.
And then continuously just don't,
they just don't tune in,
doesn't.
It's like fuck,
I don't know what it is,
I just don't understand this.
Just beltour have real problems with
their ratings when they air it.
Um,
I don't know exactly what the ratings
are.
I know that they're,
uh,
they're average.
They're not super fantastic on any.
So it's below what the averages for the
MMA fights.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure man.
It's a bummer to real fucking bummer
because for,
for anybody who's a fan,
anybody who likes watching it like shit,
like that event in La,
that last man standing.
Holy Fuck.
Was that fun?
That was crazy.
Yeah,
that was.
That was probably one of the best
kickbox Siemens was the buscot boxing
event I've ever been to.
Yeah,
me too.
The whole energy and the forum just in
general,
that layout of that was,
was bad ass
that.
Yeah,
that form is perfect for that.
I mean it,
everybody knew it was a special night
that it was crazy,
you know,
that they were doing this,
what is it like knowing that like how
much time do you have in between your
second and third fight and everything is
fucked up and sore and you know,
you're about to go into another fight.
I think it's probably like 30 minutes,
30,
40 minutes.
Maybe one more.
One other fight between you.
So just enough time for everything to
start hurting.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I guess I was just because of the money,
like I knew that each time my father was
going to get more money and that was
like my focus in the 30 minutes,
like not wanting to go back out and
never crossed my mind,
you know?
Versus if I think if I wasn't getting
paid for it,
I'd be like,
oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
that was fine.
You know what I mean?
So that's why I was asking about those
ultra marathons,
how they get paid for it or not because
I don't think that would be my main
focus.
You say that,
but I think that if you were there,
just your competitive spirit would kick
in and you would go,
let me see what I could fucking do here.
Give me another minute hand and a
cigarette.
Yeah,
you're at mile 79 and you're like,
shit I'll have to do is 21 more miles.
I could do that now.
Do you think you'd like to fight in a
tournament like old school,
Ufc one style?
Oh,
there's one to,
to uh,
you know,
being part of the,
towards tournament,
it was dope being a part of like a
monthly tournaments.
Right.
I've always wanted to be like,
you know,
was,
was good.
Would again,
you know,
find some of the best fighters in the
world three times a night.
Yeah.
That's really what's going to test you
to me.
So the,
yeah,
there's so many factors involved.
So many variables,
right?
Like your opponent could get up
quick first round knockout,
and you could go a three round war,
you know,
and then you face each other in the next
round.
It's just,
I get the commissions not wanting
to do it anymore.
I get it.
The only place that would let you do is
probably like one of them,
native American casinos.
It's like,
come on in,
come on in.
Got The commission is the commission of
problem.
I think they would do it in California.
Do you think?
So it did with glory when I did it.
Yeah.
But that's kickboxing.
I don't know if they would do that with
mma.
Kickboxing.
It's wildly widely criticized.
A lot of people think that was a bad
idea.
I think the way they can do it with
kickboxing is because of boxing.
The boxing rule says up to 12 rounds or
whatever.
So for kickboxing,
that's three fights.
Yeah.
I don't know how that works with them.
I may though that makes sense with
kickboxing.
That make sense?
Because I think they probably would have
a hard time saying like,
have Daniel can fight 10 rounds of Ima
may tonight.
That's what's the most rounds of
kickboxing you ever fought in the night.
But other than that tournament like one
single fight,
a five,
five rounds when I was probably more
times.
Always,
always,
always like that.
Right.
Why is that?
Um,
I think that the rule set and Thailand
is based primarily around gambling.
It's like human cock fighting is what
tie isn't in Thailand essentially it
sounds negative,
but it's Kinda that way everybody in the
audience is,
is gambling and betting and yelling and
motioning back and forth.
The treatment bedding.
So like in Thailand it's a three minute
round,
but it's two minute rest,
which I think is awesome.
That is awesome.
But yeah,
I follow for the WBC world title over
there.
And Wow,
what year was this Jamie?
They played the music.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
And I find a Roger Dominance Stadium and
Thailand,
which is like one of the.
Wow.
I was just dumb.
And,
and one or the two being one.
So I fought over there.
Uh,
the two minute rest is cool except that
you kind of run out of things to talk
about like my coach.
And I was like,
so I'm like looking at ring girls out,
fight a tie guy.
Uh,
no,
I'm both times now.
First Time I fought a guy from Argentina
at Roger Stadium and the second time
I've bought a car ped car at Pythian
from Golden Glory.
Jim,
for the WBC world title.
Now when you,
um,
fight over there in Thailand,
did they still expect Westerners to take
it easy on that first round?
Because the idea is during the first
round most ties,
they go fairly light because they were
ready for the bedding to get
established.
They don't want to go.
I think you don't want to come out too
strong because then nobody will bet on
you are against the other person.
I don't think they expect that from the
foreigners though.
Just as a whole.
They think that the foreigners suck.
Like they think like foreigners won't
block leg kicks.
A lot of times you'll see like the ties
come out and just wreck the foreigner in
the first round and again.
So yeah,
I don't think they're,
they're expecting the foreigners to
participate.
So I would love to go back in time
and watch Ramon decker when he first got
there and that was like the golden era
of
can we tie in like the nineties when,
when they didn't have the,
you know,
like right now it's the first round.
They don't really fight the second and
third round.
They fight in the fourth round that they
may or may not fight depending on who I
know who's who won the first two.
They take it off because they do nothing
really.
I mean not nothing but almost nothing.
They're not really trying to win because
they know they're going to fight in a
week and then like in the golden era of
was like when like those guys would come
out and just,
it was a prime time and everybody would
fight every round and it was supposedly
was better.
Does Ramon decker fights?
Anybody who doesn't know anything about
Moitai?
Go on Youtube right now and watch Ramon
dekkers and watch chaos.
That dude,
he fought guys who was his size to that
was what was interesting about him is
like he was a small guy.
It wasn't like a big guy who was going
over there to fight the ties.
He was their size.
Yeah.
And he felt like the top,
top,
top guys and like the and like their
pro,
which is pretty rare now you see like
Sanchez,
super famous,
but like [inaudible] is,
is like the celebrity guy who's fighting
like the older,
heavier ties,
like the,
the top ties right now in Thailand at
120 pounds,
15 pounds and they're like 16 years old.
It was like the top guys.
Right?
Then you build a name where you're big
enough name that the foreigners know
about you,
the rest of the world and market you and
then you fight,
you know,
you go to America and in American you go
to wherever.
So He's like a Samurai,
blue cow.
Those guys,
he's fighting constantly and he seems to
be fighting on the road a lot.
I'll go to these weird places and fight
some dude who looks like he's in real
trouble almost immediately.
Right?
Well,
they're like,
oh,
we're going to bring sunshine over for
this fight.
And like always got to fight somebody.
They tarred.
Uh,
and then a lot of times the ties don't
fight each other.
Like it's very rare that you'll see
outside of like a tie stadium.
Um,
you know,
you never hardly,
you're not going to see yahtzee classify
boot cow or like a tie versus they,
the ties to kill the foreigners and then
still be on the same team has got such
an interesting style too,
because if you looked at him,
if you only saw like a silhouette and
you saw him move around,
you'd go immediately.
Oh,
that's her.
You could tell instantly,
yeah,
it's constantly moving,
shuffling his feet,
switching back and forth,
real light on his feet.
He just moves different than everybody
else.
He does like the old wiper boron was
like the original martial art of the
turned into a tie.
If you watched like the old Tony John
like on bark or whatever and they run up
on your leg and like dropping the ball
on your head was like the [inaudible]
stuff and like a lot of the techniques
that st jude does,
like the cartwheel kick or like the
games that he plays a lot.
Silla is another one that's really
similar to him on the wash.
You just,
when they've met laird
Zilla fight in lion fight against a do
with zero fights.
They let him it with zero fights.
The dude had zero Moy Thai fights over
$400.
He got up to the top and he had kicked
this dude into another dimension,
but it was one of those things where it
was inevitable from the first minute of
the first round.
You like this guy was an mma fighter.
Not a bad fighter,
but just doesn't belong in there with
laird zillow.
It was ridiculous.
Yeah,
and when would I put it online?
The please don't ever do that again.
They're like glue.
Connor Mcgregor's going floyd.
Floyd.
Merriweather.
Yeah,
that's $100,000,000,
bro.
Kind of different.
Pretty sure.
Like if I didn't pay that guy anywhere
close to that,
pretty sure that guy got his head
knocked off for 10 bucks and it wasn't
the same.
That guy is not conor mcgregor either.
Right?
I mean if conor Mcgregor Zilla at an MMA
fight or more Thai fight,
I go,
okay,
let's see what happens.
You know,
I mean,
I don't think he's going to win,
but that might be interesting.
But you know,
seeing those guys in the real high level
guys and seeing like what they are able
to do,
seeing the way they move and it's so
important for,
especially for mma guys that don't
understand the levels of striking,
that there's.
When guys are just striking,
there are just,
there's some elite upon elite upon elite
levels.
You know?
I mean,
it's such a black pillow versus a
bluebell.
Yeah,
it'd be like a really bad ass blue belt.
The black belt,
you're just completely lost,
like it's not even close to just getting
dominated.
Yeah,
you can just get shot down,
you know,
or like you're a good high school
wrestler and you go against the world
chair.
Yeah.
That's been one of the more unique
things about combat sports is that there
are these deep,
deep levels and you don't,
you know,
sometimes you need to see like a guy
like Khabib number got madoff is a
perfect example.
You got to see him fight against guys
who you know are bad ass and see him
smush them.
Just the real difference.
Right?
Yeah.
They realized where this Guy Zach,
because he's not doing anything.
It's not like he's doing jumped three
60,
we'll kicks in the that nobody else can
do.
He's doing things that everybody else
does.
He's just doing.
I'm at a level that no one else is doing
it now.
It's crazy.
He's wrestling is like 10 times the
level of like a lot of Russell's there
could be.
Have you ever trained with them?
Never tried water.
He impresses me with like,
you know,
watching them fight.
Who was the best wrestler at American
top team when you were there,
what would you think,
do you think is the best recipe you
train?
What did.
I mean he wasn't a fighter.
Had to be Brown.
I mean Brown.
He is a dog.
Just coach wise.
He was just,
what's his name?
Mike Brown.
It was brown.
He might wouldn't know.
Where's he out of act?
No,
but where it was he was he dressing her?
I'm saying Mike Brownie,
not a um,
a,
a fighter was a coach.
Mike Browning was probably the best
wrestler at.
Oh,
the coach was interesting.
My brother just had his hands.
He was movement and strength.
Just a dog and he wasn't a fighter,
not just wrestling.
Yeah.
But he,
he had a college career too though.
Yeah.
Where'd he go?
I think it was in Boston maybe.
Or what was my brand new from up north
somewhere.
So he's never had any MMA fights.
No Brownie has.
Yeah.
How many of you have fought for the UFC
for four?
Fucking.
What was that before UFC or that young?
Um,
be uriah a WC had a good career.
Oh,
Mike Brown.
You're sounding.
You're seeing Brownie is Mike Brown?
I was like,
who's this?
Browning talking about it and I fought
for the UFC.
Was going through my Rolodex.
Browning.
Who's browning?
No,
Mike Brown's brother right now.
He's a,
he was a bad motherfucker in his day.
Cool motherfucker to do like he's
brother.
Favorite person I fuck with.
Well,
he's a great coach now too.
He was in Colby Covington,
scorn of this weekend and they told me
after the fight,
he's like,
dude,
this kid's cardio is insane.
He's like,
it's insane.
He goes,
I think it might be like a,
just a natural gift that he has.
I mean he trains really,
really hard,
but he said his cardio.
It's just off the charts.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Interesting.
It's funny how much attention he like if
he wasn't that good before,
but it is like he got a ton of fucking
intention.
It's really started talking shit.
Oh,
for sure.
I mean just the temp room.
Yeah.
Well the talk and shit.
Got them to the dance,
but beating my other way,
he beat my,
uh,
everybody had to open their eyes up and
go home.
But a lot of people had doubts.
They were like,
dos Anjos is a fucking straight up
assassin.
He's going in there at gun against.
They got fucked up.
Robbie lawler got merk.
Neil Magni like,
how's he going to beat this guy?
And he beat the shit out of him.
He literally beat him every round.
It was crazy like he watching.
I mean maybe you could give him the
first round of Dos Anjos and you know,
he was always a threat because he's
still got power,
but colby just on end it was like Nick
Diaz style just pop,
pop,
constant,
constant attack,
constant kicking them,
constant punching them.
I was very impressed,
very impressed.
Watch it.
I didn't see it.
So I can't really say anything.
Very impressive man.
That the most impressive thing was the
pace he put on them because they'll.
Santos is known for his cardio and he
had a real problem with that cardio when
he was at 1:55
because he had diminished his body so
much and then he moves up to one 70 and
you're like,
well,
now he literally doubled his output.
If you look at the strikes per minute in
the 155 pound division and then one 70,
it was double at one 70 and still
colby melted them.
Just just stayed.
Stayed on and kept that heat on.
It was crazy.
So impressive.
Very impressive.
But now he's got tyron so mad.
Tyrone wants to fucking kill him.
That's a different person like tyron
hasn't so much because he hates him.
All the shit talking colby has been
doing.
He did interviews with people.
We told them don't bring up colbys name.
I don't want you to even bring up his
name because he didn't want colby
getting any attention,
but now it's too late.
Now.
Anyone's name other than his brother all
the time on any show ever.
Period.
Ever.
We're going to fight now.
He should be happy.
That guy talks a lot of shit now because
that's what's gonna make them money,
right?
I mean fuck you go from.
How do you feel about shit talking?
I was never shit talker but because I
never wanted to be that guy,
that shit talk shit coming back it up.
So I like when people talk shit because
I'm gonna beat your ass anyway,
but you know it works for some.
It doesn't.
Like I said for me it was,
I was never one of those guys but it has
been one of those things that you see
every,
every couple of years.
It's the one guy that stands out from
talking shit and it's like I had worked
for him.
They just start to see everybody tried
to trickle it.
Well I think connor did that for a lot
of people,
but colby saying some hilarious shit.
Okay.
Take this belt and bring it to Donald
Trump.
Shit.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
It's fucking funny though,
man.
Thing Sheldon.
Chill.
It was like,
it obviously fun,
like just that's obviously bullshit,
but it's fucking works.
Yeah,
exactly.
But Charles still the bus might see the
manager and make me watch him talk about
anything.
I really like.
What?
He's a smart dude.
It's really good because little is a
instagram videos that he does in his
car.
We were fucking great.
They're excellent.
Fucking great.
I would take a class from chill on how
to like talk shit.
Do that shit.
I would totally do it.
Yeah,
man.
When he was fighting Anderson Silva,
those.
Those were the glory days of Shit.
Talking in MMA.
He opened up the door for everybody.
Oh,
the feeding the Nogueira brothers a
carrot.
Carrot got his bus was a donkey.
I didn't know that.
They had the internet there.
I swear.
I didn't know.
I thought it was on a private forum.
The internet
and eyes balls.
He went over and did the ultimate
fighter in Brazil.
I mean,
went over to Brazil,
stayed there for six weeks and did the
ultimate fighter and coached alongside
vandelay and vandelay got jumped by a
Dieta and vandelay got so goofy on the
show that vandelay last Brazilian fans
because vandelay was coming after him
and shale was trying to be calm about it
and was like,
look,
you know,
like don't touch me,
don't come near me.
And you know,
vandelay comes near him,
he grabs him,
takes him down,
and he's like,
it was so,
it was so interesting.
Like watching him turn it all around and
people mad at Vanderbilt.
I mean the Brazilians were mad.
Evacuated the like you're making us look
bad.
A perfect place.
A perfect.
Perfect.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
there's a time and a place for shit
talking and this is the time and this is
the place.
It just seems like to make money now.
It's,
it's such a wise move.
I mean it's sports entertainment at the
end of the day,
regardless of what anybody wants to say
or think about it.
And like I'd rather.
I mean I've watched two guys that aren't
that good.
If I,
you know,
like the tough man contest,
so if it's marketed right and think the
bouncers and bartenders are like
whatever,
like the entertainment,
it's entertainment.
Some of the best fights have been
against guys who aren't some of the best
fighters.
Splutter being I'd love that guy was the
best fights ever.
Sure.
I'm going to start like a fucking tough
man contest.
Promotions.
Well and even good guys who aren't world
champions.
Like when a god he fought micky ward.
We knew that they were both perfectly
matched and they were just going to
collide in the middle of the ring and
beat the fuck out of each other.
But are some of the classic boxing
matches
for sure.
Didn't have to be for the heavyweight
championship.
No,
no,
no.
I mean there's been some amazing fights
in the UFC there.
Similar to that,
like Gilbert Melendez,
verse Diego Sanchez.
That wasn't for a title.
I was one of the greatest fights of our.
See that shit was crazy.
So classic.
So it makes.
I mean I've always like that shit.
Two fighters that don't really have too
much on the line and talking shit about
a fight hype and the hype behind the
fight is what makes life.
It always does.
Yeah.
As long as you can actually still fight.
That's what's makes it interesting with
the guy with connor or a guy like colby
day can fuckin fight it.
Talking a lot of shit.
But when the,
when the,
when the bell rings,
they're backing it up.
I mean we're talking about this earlier,
but that's what bugs me the most about
cm punk was there.
He has the,
the ww II background you would think
would be like great on the mic.
You know what I mean?
And they're like maybe you can't back it
up or fight or whatever.
Like he goes from like cocky and
confident I'm the Fuck Jab or whatever
that we're going to be like,
oh,
you know,
I just believe in yourself.
Kids.
It's like really hard to listen.
I don't believe he has no physical,
like no physique.
He doesn't.
It's not like it's,
it's kind of sad.
I just shit on cm punk.
No,
listen,
you didn't shit on him.
You were honest about them.
You were honest about what you saw.
I don't think that shit on him.
Right.
He's a very nice guy.
He's a very nice guy and he's a hard
worker,
but he does not have athletic talent.
He's missing a lot and he's a showman
and when he was in the wwe,
he was allowed to say I'm not fucking
man and throw his arms up there and they
had it scripted so that he was the man.
But you know,
when you're in there with a guy like
Mike Jackson who had zero fear of him
and just was so casual and just popping
them in the face anytime he wanted to
and literally could have stopped him
anytime.
If he just got angry and want to stop
him,
he could have stopped him at any point
in the fight.
And even though he beat him decisively,
the performance was pissed white off so
bad
the way he was fighting that.
He called him a fucking idiot and he
said,
I'll never fight in the UFC again.
Anyone.
So like if Mike Jackson went out there
and just start cm punk with a right hand
left hook combination and that was the
end of it,
they would say,
well cm punk,
you gave it a shot.
That's it.
It's over.
Mike,
who would you like to fight next?
And now it's like,
you know,
you're not even fighting in the UFC
anymore because you should have,
you should have stopped him like what
you were doing.
He tickled him fucking it.
I'll make a joke of the sport,
like it's already like a joke because if
this guy,
everyone thinks punk punks like fucking
joke.
I guess he is,
but like don't make a joke of the sport
and like not just like poking fun of the
fence.
I get rid and it's coming from.
I get ridiculous comment as to how to
starched stem.
Yeah,
it's the whole thing was,
it was very weird.
The whole thing was very weird,
was like right away when you see cm punk
holding,
holding his hands up and moving stiff
and throwing kicks.
So like,
oh Jesus,
like I don't like that being on paper
view.
I understand that they're,
they're selling paper view cards,
but paper view in the UFC should be the
elite fighters.
Curtis blades versus Alistair overeem.
Should have been on that paper view
card.
That's what should have been there.
Not,
not what we got to see.
You know,
what we got to see was just.
Yeah,
I don't like when it's like,
like you're playing a trick on the
fence,
you know what I mean?
Promoting this guys if you something and
then it's like inspiring videos come out
and it's like,
what the fuck is this?
Inspiring?
Videos are crazy.
Awful.
It was like a guy who just showed that
as far awful.
It's like you took a dude who's no
wrestling background,
no nothing,
or this one I want you to do.
This is a jab.
It was the right hand is when you throw
a kick.
I want you to pivot.
Your hips go ahead and there as bar.
I mean he just.
He doesn't have the ability to move his
body.
Right.
There's a lot of guys that you could
take out there that are track and field
guys or football players and you could
get them to fight better than him in a
couple of weeks easily because they're
athletes,
they're athletes.
They would understand how to shift their
weight,
throw a punch,
and yet the,
the sparring videos that I saw was,
I think it was his first fight,
but even then he wasn't.
He signed for like two years before he
had his first fight or something like
that.
There's no way that you're six years
deep in the game and yet he's still at
that bad.
You know what I mean?
He doesn't have any talent.
It's all it is.
It just doesn't have physical talent or
whatever for whatever reason,
whether it's a,
he,
his approach,
his intensity,
whether it's,
it's not as coaching.
So at Duke fucking Rufus,
you know,
I mean,
it has to do with cushman that he talks
about Duke roufus hit and one of the
prefects.
He said,
uh,
how do you see this fight?
It's like,
oh,
I really like a head kick to would love
to see a head kick and like,
I don't think that's going to happen.
Oh,
that's so crazy.
That is.
So,
that's such a crazy thing to say.
Um,
you know,
Duke's a beautiful person.
He's a great guy in every,
every sense of the word.
He just says he's a great guy.
He did his best.
You know,
there's only so much you could do.
No,
I mean,
I'm sure
you would love working with Duke.
I'm sure he would love working with you
if you and duke work together.
I'm sure you guys would have a great old
time because you're Joe fucking
chilling.
Right?
And he's Duke fucking relevance,
you know,
let them know.
But you know what I mean.
I mean,
you have to have something to work with,
you know,
I mean if duke just grabbed some dude
from a gas station that has been
drinking beer and smoking cigarettes his
whole life and had him in a fight in six
months,
how much can you,
we expect.
But I would rather see that fight
against these other ones.
Right.
Let's find out how that one would go.
Well,
a guy,
you can find it a gas station.
What's interesting is they both.
Both guys fought micky gall first.
Just weird.
Did you see his instagram?
Mickey's?
Yeah,
he did like his own pre-fight a analysis
of how it was going to go.
It was really good.
Yeah.
Well,
um,
you know,
that was a disaster when I saw Mickey
fight and then I saw that it was going
to fight cm punk.
I was like,
who said Yes to this?
Why the fuck would you say yes to this?
This is a hundred percent guaranteed
brain damage.
There's no way you're going to beat him.
There's not.
You don't have a goddamn chance in hell.
You have no chance.
And I was saying that people get mad at
me.
The CM punk fans get mad at me.
I'm like,
look,
this is what I do.
My job is to analyze shit.
I look.
I look at fighters,
I look at it,
I understand what I'm talking about,
man.
This is like,
I've got a pit bull and I'm going to put
them in a cage with a puppy.
What do you think's gonna Happen?
The pit is going to kill the puppy.
This is what?
This is how it works.
This isn't like,
this isn't maybe that puppy going to
grab him by the face.
No,
no,
no.
Listen to me.
I'm telling you,
this is how bad this matchup is.
This is a,
this is a Brazilian jujitsu brown belt
with a nasty back game.
Strong and fast.
You look at,
uh,
the matchup with the cm punk just had
Mike Jackson Mckee beat my checks in and
I'm like under a minute.
So much him took his back,
strangle him.
He's a bit out here training with me for
like the three months now.
And the kids getting really good
striking is getting really,
really good.
He's fucking talented men.
Really good.
And he talks a lot of shit too that he's
good.
Plus has got hilarious walkout music
when it comes down to.
Oh Mickey,
I to convince him since he got here,
I called his phone and it's like,
you know,
those people have this ring back songs
and they're like,
fucking horrible.
Yeah.
Elevator music.
And he answers and I'm like,
dude,
turn that fucking shit off.
You change it or at least have it be.
Hey Mickey,
you're so fine.
And what is his music on some trash?
It's just elevator.
Doesn't like something awful.
Fucking change it.
Mickey.
That's when is he fighting again?
Uh,
I don't think it has anything booked
yet.
I think he's,
he's calling show Sean Shelby.
So he's working with you with this
tracking?
Yep.
No know he's helped me with my ground
game.
And who was he working with his ground
game out here?
Uh,
uh,
Jason Manly and a Bomba Fast Gonzales.
Where's that out of a Bama
trades of me.
And Jason Manly is a,
the training that muscle farm.
That's cool.
So where is he a?
Is He staying in Burbank out there as
you stay in there?
You,
he's standing there.
Me and I'm a Eagle Rock.
Nice.
She's actually roommates with Eve
Edwards.
No,
Shit.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's right.
Here we got me.
I forget this little love eve.
Genesis dude thing going.
Yeah man,
he's great,
isn't he?
He's a great dude.
Crazy great dude.
He's a very good.
On the desk too,
it's interesting to see like a former
fighters on the desk,
like some dudes are lost and some dudes
are smooth.
Some humans are very good at it.
He's.
I think he's as great.
Right?
It's fairly.
I think he's one of my favorite ones to
watch.
Yeah.
I tweeted about it like years ago when
he first started doing.
I'm like,
diet,
really appreciate him doing it.
You know,
I'm Mike Bisping is very good at it too.
Although he's been him.
Colby got out.
It was a little awkward.
They went after it after the uh,
after the fight.
Bisbing can't not talk shit himself,
which I kinda,
I kinda,
I really appreciate that about him
actually.
Well he's,
he's a dog man.
His,
his competitive drive is pretty intense.
You know,
bisping is in my opinion,
like one of the best,
but he's like one of the best poster
boys for just hard work,
mental toughness and determination and
also being that like British due to
that,
the bar that'll have a beard tell you to
go fuck herself and piss off.
Well the.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's good.
He's got problems with his other eye now
to he.
Yeah.
You got some sort of a detachment in his
other eye is good.
I thought they were going to fix fix
one.
I thought it was going to get better or
something.
He's got some sort of oil in it that
protects it before he retires and then
when he retires he's going to get it
operated on to fix it,
but now he has a new problem with his
right eye.
He was seeing some flash or something
like that,
his right eye and he went to the doctor
and found out it's kind of detachment
there and he's like,
fuck this.
I'm done.
Because he was going to have one more
fight and now he's like,
I'm done.
He did it all,
man.
He won the ultimate fighter.
He won the title,
you know,
and,
and now he's a good analyst to the desk
because she thing go on his podcast.
I think you're great too.
He's doing good.
That is a nice thing to write some
movies.
Yeah.
He's always got something going on.
Um,
it's nice that guys do have those other
options too.
Like podcasts and different things.
Now there's,
there's ways out,
you know,
especially looking at like what jobs
done.
Sharp has taken it to a whole nother
level.
I mean,
he's as far as guys being able to get
out of out of the fight game and then
make a living as a podcast.
He's fucking doing stand up now and
headlining clubs and shit and traveling
all over the country.
And He's good man.
He's fucking funny.
He's a funny dude.
It's hilarious.
You know,
it's just nice that fighters have
options because,
you know,
seeing the guy stick around when he
shouldn't be doing it anymore.
It's one of the hardest things for sure.
And then they'll be like all the nfl
guys or any pro sport.
Most of these guys are broke by the end
with him like four years of when they
finish.
And uh,
yeah,
there's not a whole lot of other options
for a lot of the guys.
So I think it's good.
It's nice that we have other options for
sure.
So would you sign it?
You showed everybody the way here,
Joe.
There's a way,
you know,
there's a way.
There's ways now,
especially with the Internet man,
there's just crazy ways.
I mean,
how much money think mighty mouse makes
on his twitch stream,
let's say a decent amount.
I don't know how much this is like the
video game dudes twitch stream and
they're not even like the best gamers in
the world and they make thousands and
thousands of pages on there all the
time.
Would you say is planning something
right now?
Sugar.
Sean's in it too bad.
Not that we're going to watch it,
but he had song rampage does that too?
I think so.
Yeah.
He's a big Gamer.
He's always talking about.
Is he still active?
Is he still gonna fight again?
Yeah.
I was trying to get a fight with him not
too long ago and uh,
I'm not sure what.
Well he's like 290 pounds right now,
but I feel like at half six figure that
for that size I could do that.
Could do that.
That could be read pitch.
I don't know if I'd go for like Brock
Lesnar.
Well,
the rates lower cut a heavyweight we're
talking about because he doesn't,
he doesn't try to take it down,
right.
Most likely is going to try to stand
with you.
Do you have a set schedule for you
return to mma?
Uh,
I'm hopefully getting at something
around September,
August,
late August,
early September,
I think.
And you just decided that we're
kickboxing is right now.
Just doesn't have enough juice.
Uh,
yeah,
I,
uh,
you know,
I want to keep progressing financially
and uh,
you know,
uh,
like I said,
money motivates me a lot and uh,
if I reached the ceiling of the sport so
to speak,
and there's,
Oh,
I'm amazed right here,
right next door and uh,
yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
No,
yeah,
I mean,
how many more years you think you're
going to do it?
A four,
five,
four,
five.
I want to make big fights as much money
as I can.
Um,
and set up for life after fighting.
I think,
you know,
you can't just quit,
right?
You gotta find ways to market yourself
to the highest level to get as much
attention as possible.
So the irrelevant in the space that you
pass and I just don't think they
kickboxing is going to get me there.
Yeah,
man,
it's a bummer.
But I think you're right.
I think it's a smart if you're just
dealing strictly financially.
I think it's a very smart move.
It's very unfortunate.
I really wish there was a solution.
I do not know what it would be though.
I mean everybody's tried.
Spike TV tried,
they tried the paramount network.
They tried with glory.
No
one thing it also with pellets or you
know,
maybe I'll come back,
maybe there's a big fight,
you know,
maybe Musashi's like you don't want to
think I want the bills were kickboxing,
title to be
right.
Yeah,
let's do it.
So yeah.
Um,
but I would fight if they let me,
I would fight fucking kickboxing first,
win
that fight and then come back out the
same night and fight mma.
Leo.
I brought it up.
I brought it up to coker at a meeting
not too long ago where they say they
just kinda looked at me like fucking
crazy horse the same way they looked at
me when I said I wanted to fight rampage
of vandelay.
Well his deal is he back like,
what's going on with vandelay?
I don't know.
I just saw it as an opportunity when
Chell beat him,
you know,
his complaint was that,
he just took her panel,
laid on top of them,
which has been kind of my complaint for
a while.
So I figured,
but they don't want that fight.
Why don't they want their friends when
they get barely already had his face
surgery.
Doesn't want to have it done twice.
Rampage is my buddy when he just.
He just doesn't want that.
He said he wants an easy fight like
vandelay so.
Well there's a lot of history between
those two guys to.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
You'd want to fight for him?
Yeah.
He was A.
Vanderbilt was an interesting story to
write when he was fighting over in pride
and then he came over to the UFC just
completely different human being.
Yeah.
You know,
just in the rampage fights when rampage
brought them over in prod and that also
a lot of miles on them to get to think
of both things.
No.
Yeah,
she's got me thinking about felony,
talking about,
uh,
you know,
fighting and whatnot
over the felony.
The known as the crazy horse.
Crazy horse has now changed his name to
felony ladies.
Gentlemen.
No longer refer to him as crazy horse
you ever see that fight backstage is
nothing like swear swears up and down.
Yeah.
Beat them up.
So the sleep,
he definitely just somebody else will
somebody else.
But didn't he say he says he killed
vandelay city sucker punched him after
he got choked out on the video that you
see.
He fought later on that night and won by
knockout I think after being choked
unconscious in the back.
And he said he knocked out vandelay.
Oh yeah.
Yes and no.
No,
no.
It happened before.
He fought in the locker room and he went
out and won and then he,
he says he knocked out vandelay,
punched him and knocked him out.
Vandelay went out and won a decision.
So vandelay,
if he's telling the truth,
he killed vandelay earlier that night.
Yes,
exactly.
Here's the fight.
This is vandelay when you know that
doesn't even look like the same person I
know is the same person.
Yeah.
Like the Mario brothers muscles.
He tacked this dude and he got caught in
a triangle.
Very danger.
Danger.
That's it.
I forget who it was that did this to
him,
but it was one across and Gracie's black
belts.
Okay.
How big is.
How big is a felon now?
You got it?
Fifty five pounds maybe.
Probably.
Yeah.
He's out cold here,
right?
Yeah.
Cold.
Oh,
they're very nice to him.
His eyes opened up.
He's like,
what?
I think like,
uh,
you did A.
I saw a clip the other day.
The guys asked you,
uh,
what's the practical use of Jujitsu?
And you're like,
well,
I'm a street.
If we got in a fight,
I would kill you.
That's like,
I think people don't realize that like
without the ref to like stop the fight
or even those guys like they stopped
him.
Like,
okay,
I let him go.
He's already unconsciously.
That would kill you if you would be
dead.
You were dead dead if that guy doesn't
want to let go of you until your brain
doesn't work anymore.
And that's a wrap and that's that.
That's real shit.
That's my friend Eric.
Trying to come up with some excuse to
not work out.
That's why I said,
what's the practical use?
Jujitsu.
We had the fight.
I wouldn't kill.
You know the crazy horse fight.
Two guys on the basketball court got a
big fight and then he takes him down
really,
really quick.
He attacked a guy.
Oh yeah,
he fucked up sign.
Oh yeah.
Oh he's.
He thinks he's a bad ass and he doesn't.
How a fight.
Oh look at this.
Oh,
I'll punch in the back of the head.
Oh Shit.
Ooh.
Look at this thing.
And he's still trying to find him
hilarious.
He's taking that leg apart though right
here.
He's got them in the heel hook right
There's no play basketball again by the
that's in that position.
He's telling the truth though,
right?
All he has to do is Yank that fucking
thing up clockwise and that's a wrap.
Pop,
pop,
pop.
That horrible pain of getting.
He'll hooked and not tapping.
Not The business,
especially that inside.
He'll hook that is so nasty when it goes
across the body.
The amount of Torque on your knee.
This is like no way.
Unique and hang in there.
It just rips apart.
I'm good on knee surgery.
Is that that Polaris?
Well,
he does.
He does outside in inside,
but the inside one is just the outside
one.
You got a little bit more.
There's a little more movement like
this.
I mean you got to tap,
but the problem is when someone's got
you in this way across the body and then
they go like that,
man,
you got about an inch or two above it
and it's just.
It's horrible
too.
It sounds terrible.
You could hear a duck everything pulling
apart and snapping off the bone and
people screaming.
Paul Harris would not let go either.
That was his thing.
He would just hang on to heal hooks.
It sounds so bad.
I got to go with the fucking Komora.
There was,
I'm not sure what the differences,
but uh,
it sounds like at this,
in Americana,
this is the Camorra I think it was this
way,
the,
it sounded like ripping a towel.
Terry cloth towel.
If you pull it all apart and the fibers
start popping.
That's what it sounded like.
It's still here to my head.
So three tap.
I mean,
after he's like,
oh,
it's cool,
it's cool.
And I'm like,
that's fucking cool.
I didn't need to break your fucking arm.
You could have just tapped dickhead.
Yeah,
I saw.
I got to hear this shit in my head all
night.
I saw a video of a street fight.
There's another video where the dude
gets a guy in an Alma Plata and he's,
he's,
he's pushes arm up.
You see the art guys arm.
Just give out.
Oh,
the street fight I saw was like Mexico
or Brazil or some good groundwork
though.
He's nice on Omoplata in a street fight.
It's always a plus.
I mean there's a street fight.
Game is changing,
you know,
dressed for dangerous super dangerous
kid who was like on the playground.
It was like flying like karate kid.
Now they're going to be like rear naked
choke and each other fucking little
kids.
Little kids grow up watching Bela torn
the EFC and kickboxing.
They know what a leg kick is.
Now they know all that shit.
They know how to grab the back of the
head.
Other kids are yelling,
ne need.
They know what to do now.
Oh,
is this it?
Yeah,
this is.
this is awful.
The dude gets.
He brings that Lego,
that guy.
The guy on the top has no understanding
of what to do with is.
Oh,
here it is.
Oh Sir.
I'm just gonna.
Here comes here.
Comes here.
Comes,
watch this.
Get ready and it comes to noise.
Awful man sound.
Oh,
there it is.
Look at it.
Just laying fucked up backwards on his
arm.
Oh,
don't move it.
Jesus Christ.
He's just laying there like he must've
been drunk too because he's like,
he didn't even pull his arm out.
He had no idea what he was doing.
Listen.
Yeah.
Do you guys see that?
You don't know your smoke,
Daniel?
Is that what that is?
Cigarettes there.
These are empty.
It was something else in here.
Come on man.
Do you smoke cigarettes?
Yes.
Yes I do.
How often you smoke?
Soon as I get out of here.
As soon as you get out of here.
How many?
How many a day to go?
Uh,
I don't know.
Probably about half a back.
Jesus hanging out with this motherfucker
is.
Okay.
This is part of.
You just got to get it.
Got a ticket.
Just go ahead and get a job.
Just looking out for your best
interests,
man.
Have you ever tried to switch to vape or
anything like that?
Uh,
I've done man.
Listen,
I've done it all.
Vape.
I've chewed,
have tried to stop everything.
I just,
I'm a individual or just
you're an individual individually.
Were you smoking when you were the.
You are the current war.
Military Champ holds.
I was like,
damn,
that's so crazy.
We've spoken to.
I was like chewing in smoking since I
was 12.
does a lot of Thai fighters to smoke,
right?
Scott Boskey doesn't need Disney.
Always smoke.
Does that.
Makes a lot of metal,
a lot of fires.
I don't want to put it out there like,
but billy Bob last but a lot of fighters
that,
you know,
at high level in the UFC,
smoke cigarettes.
I used to try to hide it like they used
to be one thing.
I'm trying to hide it and then you
always say,
oh I can't believe your athlete.
You're smoking until I leave me the fuck
alone.
I hear you talk and they go,
man,
you an 80 year old blue center fuck's
going on with your voice man cigarettes.
They give you that hard living voice.
There's definitely a benefit and a level
two,
like not hiding who you are.
And again I was just talking to somebody
about that today.
Like it is nice to that I could say that
I smoke weed and be myself and whatever.
Shit.
Especially we'd know,
you know,
I mean there's a lot of people that have
some dumb ideas about what we does to
you,
you know,
and it's nice that guys like you were
out about it so he could realize like no
real smart guys like you were out there
to pro athletes,
but like I'm a stoner,
I'm a comedian.
Like makes sense.
But pro athletes like seeing like that,
a guy like who takes care of his body,
smoke Swedes,
not,
it's not ruined in his car.
He was like.
The other thing is that people want to
think that it's lazy.
Yeah.
That's what bothers me most about the
misconception of it as like that you're
not a productive person,
that you just sit around the house and
that someday,
like on Sunday I sit around the house
high motherfucker Shit.
But every other day I'm working my ass
off constantly
stays off for sure.
For sure.
There's a photo in the green room from
Ryan Loco.
Shout out to Ryan.
You a smoking cigarettes.
It is that law firm.
Last man standing.
It's in between fights.
Uh,
yeah.
I think it will.
I don't know if it was last man standing
or if it was,
it was a locker room,
one of the glory fights.
I don't know if it was between flights
or not.
Yeah,
there it is.
That's up in the green room right now.
Officers.
It was like a Jimmy Hendrix and Elvis.
Right?
With the same.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I got a gang of new ones coming now.
I got um,
Steven Tyler when he was a teenager,
got arrested for weed.
I got him.
I got conor Mcgregor.
Conor Mcgregor Mug shot.
I got the real Jimi Hendrix Mugshot,
not the,
not the photo that we had on before,
which was like his real mug shot label,
but the photo was from one of them,
Jimmy Hendrix experience photos.
We got the real mugshot photo.
Now.
Jimi Hendrix hasn't been heroin and I'm
trying to go to Toronto with that
heroin.
Here it is right there.
Yeah.
When someone's tried to tell me Jimi
Hendrix didn't do heroin.
Well tell that to the Toronto Police
Department when they fuck it.
Arrested him for it.
There's a picture of me on instagram.
I saw was a Bruno Mars,
fucking a justin beaver to other Brits
celebrities,
wherever they were all smiling in their
mugshot and it was like when you know
you have
money,
they just got Vince Vaughn.
Yeah.
They just busted him.
Dui Sucks.
Good chicken and drive is a good.
I got both.
I got a Dui when I was 20,
22 on shrooms,
shrooms and drug tested you patent.
They didn't give me for this rooms.
They fucking help for the deal.
I would think that maybe the shrooms
would help balance out the booze problem
was.
I kept arguing with the guy and he was
like trying to get me to blow on the
street and I'm like Oh yeah,
nothing happening like pretending to
blow and then they take me downtown and
I was like in and out of like falling
asleep and they kept like waking up and
they had like the Dui,
a breathalyzer machine.
It looks like kind of like this or
whatever.
The actual big machine.
And I remember like arguing with him
like,
what if it was,
if I don't blow and he's like,
the,
you get suspended for six months.
And I'm like,
what if I blow and it's a d in a bad as
a unit.
He was suspended for a year and I'm
like.
And then I asked them that back and
forth like 20 times I kept falling
asleep.
I ended up,
I ended up not blowing.
It would make you want to not blow like
what are you?
Fucking stupid.
So by the time,
yeah,
go to jail or you go to court anyway,
your suspensions almost up.
So I ended up,
I ended up getting off on that because
it was a uh,
they pulled me over for turning the
wrong way on a one way street.
But I just showed that I wasn't,
I didn't do any field stuff
already.
Tests,
I'm not saying you shouldn't drink and
drive,
I'm not,
I'm trying to pick that.
But if you do drink,
uh,
during,
yeah,
I didn't do the field sobriety tests.
So they didn't have any probable cause
that it was actually drunk.
And when he didn't blow and uh,
they said,
well,
he was driving the wrong way in one way
street.
And I was like,
I've never been to that area before.
So side note technique,
don't blow.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Never had a dui.
Good for you know,
driving a fucking motorcycle,
man.
You better be silver will punch you
smoking cigarettes,
not paying attention what you're doing
with Uber and lyft and all this shit.
Now it's Kinda,
it's pretty responsible to get a fucking
Dui.
I bet it's dropped down significantly
because of uber and lyft are really bad.
It has for sure.
I think so.
Listen Boys,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Thanks for bringing me all this stuff,
Daniel.
Much love and appreciate you.
Hey,
my pleasure dude.
And Best of luck in your recovery.
It's a great story.
I love hearing it.
And all the best man.
Joe Schilling and Daniel Straus on
twitter and on instagram.
Joe Underscores shilling.
And you know,
I had this fucking planet.
I was going to keep saying my,
uh,
my instagram password throughout the
whole show and I fucking forgot to Joel
underscore chilling on instagram.
There you go.
Holler at your boy college boy.